[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online marriage is blessing Kelly Ripa
celebrated the best father husband and
friend she knows mark consuelos is 46th
birthday Thursday by posting a series of
sweet snaps to Instagram like this one
of the two staring into each other's
eyes mark hanging with their kids and
this smokin shot of him getting out of
the water that's really what fuels meet
flip or flop Star Trek el Moussa took to
the gram to flaunt his insanely ripped
bod while working out in the gym writing
his in the quote best shape of his life
meanwhile Russell Crowe clapped back at
Howard Stern for allegedly body shaming
him after pictures emerged of the actor
playing rugby in Australia looking a bit
fuller Russell hilariously tweeted I can
benchpress young Howard he cannot say
the same and Mandy Moore posted this
adorable throwback shot with Justin
Timberlake from 1999 when she was the
opening act for in sync
[Music]
you